this week on genv cast it into the
fire destroy
it no there's only one more episode of
gen V left and I'm over here like why
God why yes who knows how long it'll be
before season four of the boys drops but
until then we have some gen V to TI us
over which has really turned out to be
an absolutely phenomenal spin-off in
this video we'll be taking a deep dive
into the episode its connection to
season 1's tragic downfall of trans
Oceanic Flight 37 and theorizing what
Victoria will do with the virus who will
be the new Dean and who Grace mallerie
was talking to on the phone so make sure
to like And subscribe I have a new
Little Cricket wardrobe I need to
collect and these panties aren't going
to buy themselves the title of episode 7
is sick which is basically what happened
to me after watching what Victoria
Newman did to Dr cardosa I also now have
a strange craving for fresa oh my
God
a soup by the name of rich is brought
into a Woods containment cell along with
three other soups one of them Andy has
been injected with the new contagious
soup killing virus created by Dr cardosa
at the behest of Dean and DEET both rich
and Andy were not on Professor Brink's
list of current prisoners that Andre
found in episode 2 so either this wasn't
a comprehensive list or gulan takes new
subjects as it deems fit when Rich
enters the cell asks what did I do did
he come from another cell or was he
taken from up top last episode we heard
Dean Shetty order Dr cardosa to make the
virus both lethal and highly contagious
with poor Betsy here being the first to
go as it currently stands the virus can
only be contracted via bodily fluids but
Chetty wants it Airborne something
cardosa says would spread like wildfire
among the soup Community if it were to
get out later on in the episode we'll
learn that cardosa estimates he's 10
months away from making an Airborne
version now cardosa here is right to
question shedy on why vot would want to
make such a virus that would essentially
destroy its bread and butter F has built
itself around superheroes so why create
something that would destroy them that's
because Dean shett has gone Rogue when
Marie and Jordan break into her office
they find a file folder with newspaper
clippings and files on trans Oceanic
Flight 37 in season one of the boys
homelander and queen mave were tasked
with bringing this flight to safety
after was taken over by terrorists I'm
going to save everyone here don't worry
about it a few moments later you say the
back laser you godamn it but there's a
terrorist in the cockpit who Gets Zapped
by homelander causing the flight
controls to malfunction even if someone
could fly the plane they wouldn't be
able to in shed's office Marie and
Jordan uncover a classified picture of
the recovered cockpit showing
homelanders laser having slashed through
the controls now it's possible that
homelander destruction of the controls
was no accident that it was all planned
at the time meline Stillwell was trying
to get va's superheroes into the
military and what better way to show the
world needs soups than a deadly
terrorist attack if they let us into the
military then this will never happen
again so if Dean Shetty has this
Photograph she knows that Not only was
homelander on that flight but its
Downing was caused by him and VA covered
it up this is why Dean Shetty wants a
virus that will kill all soups as
revenge for killing her husband Paul and
11-year-old daughter Lily who were on
that flight it's also why she goes
against VA a company that routinely
covers up the terrible crimes of their
quote unquote Heroes cardosa threatens
to expose Shetty but what will VA do to
him when they find out he's created a
soup killing virus it's put him in a
very precarious situation one which
finds him drunkenly breaking into the
Dean's office and pissing in her whiskey
meanwhile Kate calls shett hoping to
arrange a Meetup this is all a plan to
get her alone so that the gang can
expose Shetty for everything she's done
but Shetty has an important meeting
downtown one with Grace mallerie former
deputy director of the CIA and founder
of the boys the last time we saw her she
was putting Soldier Boy to sleep Shetty
tells Kate to calm down and take more of
her medication medication she first gave
Kate years ago which numbs her powers
with her currently off them the voices
in her head come back but those voices
are actually the thoughts of people
around her the ability to hear people's
thoughts is exceptionally powerful and
I'm looking forward to how Kate will use
this power in the episodes and Seasons
to come the diner is decked out with
Superhero Funko Pops like those we saw
in episode one a homelander doll and a
campaign poster for Victoria Newman in
season 3 of the boys we learned that
Victoria Newman is running for vice
president alongside presidential
candidate Robert Singer Robert Singer is
the the current US Secretary of Defense
and once held a meeting with Stan Edgar
then CEO of va to discuss the
incorporation of soups into the military
he's named after Robert Singer the
co-showrunner of Supernatural which gen
V creator Eric kryy also produced the TV
in the background shows us everyone's
favorite fair and balance news reporter
Cameron Coleman it's October and we're
bringing you no tricks just the greatest
treat of all the truth he's talking
about that no good anti-p socialist
Victoria Newman coming to speak at gulan
you can bet there's going to be a ton of
push backs on a candidate who's seen
amongst the soup Community as being
anti-p remember she's the head of the
fbsa the Federal Bureau of superhuman
Affairs an organization that
investigates and prosecutes soups
however in her defense she states that
this has resulted in both lower soup and
human deaths we'll even see graffiti
that spells out cop on her campaign
Signs Now The Gang wants to believe in
Kate after it was found out she was
wiping their memories but it's going to
take something big to earn their trust
back outside Jordan is pissed that Kate
can read their minds but Marie reminds
them that they need Kate to use her
powers on Shetty to expose the truth
about the woods there are some cool
Easter eggs here like a train promoting
Henderson beer which is a local Brewery
here in Toronto where the show is filmed
we have these soup headphone ads done in
the style of the iconic iPod ads of the
2000s and soup lives matter spray
painted on top of a poster for Newman a
nod to Black black lives matter it's
Jordan who proposes another idea as a TA
he has access to shed's office maybe
they can find some incriminating
evidence in there and give it to
Victoria Newman people are way more
likely to believe the atrocities
committed at gulin if they come from her
meanwhile Emma introduces Sam to her
room which comes with cute little
panties and even Starlight starb Raider
which you can buy online at soup
porn.com yes VOD has an actual website
where you can peruse an assortment of
adult toys unfortunately the the starb
braider is discontinued fun fact the
starb braider was one of many weapons
Kimo used in season 3 to bring down a
man known as the oligarch if you follow
VA International on Twitter you'll know
last week was Soldier Boy week at godu
and if you signed up for it you got a
complimentary bottle of lube upon
arrival which is where Emma may have
gotten this remember that Sam is on the
Run having massacred a group of soldiers
only a few episodes ago so it's
imperative that he keeps a low profile 5
minutes later
[__] got your ass well Emma goes to get
his incriminating clothes incinerated by
a pyro soup from her movement class Sam
just needs to sit tight I also thought
it was really sad to see him hold
himself up in the closet almost as if
he's more comfortable in there because
he's been brought up and confined spaces
his entire life you may have also seen
this poster for big Crazy Love 2 a movie
starring termite you may remember seeing
inside a wiener in season 3 of the boys
in episode 2 we saw a selection of
termite films only available on vot plus
vot plus the world's Premier super
streaming service sign up now snooping
around shed's office Jordan and Marie
uncover shed's true motive and it's also
quite convenient that drunk cardosa
enters blabbing about the increasing
viral infection rate in quote killing
them all so it appears to Marie and
Jordan that whatever is going down in
the woods is even more dangerous than
they imagined Shetty has to the city to
share her Creation with Grace mallerie
if there's someone who would be on the
Dean's side surely it's Grace Grace not
only founded the Boys a CIA vigilante
group tasked with bringing down V and
the seven but her own grandchildren were
killed by former member of the seven
Lamplighter Grace blackmailed
Lamplighter with a video footage of him
committing an unseen act in an attempt
to get him to spy on the seven but
Lamplighter burned her hotel room
thinking Grace was in it when actually
had had her grandchildren for Shetty the
virus gives humans a way to fight back
stating that it's us meaning humans
versus them soups and we'll see the
beginnings of this Us Versus Them
rhetoric echoed with Rufus and Sam we're
better than humans well that's pretty
racist Grace will not get behind this
calling it genocide you can't go around
killing an entire people because some of
them are doing evil acts why because if
they catch wind of what she's doing the
soups will crush you and everyone you
care about too late for that Shetty is a
woman with nothing to lose and Grace
sees the parallels between her and Billy
butcher a man who works for me one of
your fellow countrymen has the same rage
it's so consumed him that there's
nothing left regardless Shetty is going
through with this plan with or without
Grace's help but the big reveal here is
that Grace was recording this entire
conversation now who could she have been
talking to the first theory is that it's
someone in the boys she asks the person
on the other end to keep a close eye on
the dean so it has to be someone who has
the resources available to do that it
might also be Victoria Newman Victoria
Newman is the new are she's sneaking me
some off the books funding for a team
that can keep tabs on the soups Grace
and Victoria do have a history together
in exchange for information on VA
Victoria would help bring the company
down it's Grace who even escorts
Victoria out of the courtroom during the
infamous head popping episode but with
huie uncovering the Victoria is a soup
in season 3 this Theory may be less
likely back at gulkan Sam makes some new
friends with Steve the ice breathing
soup ruus and a girl credited as cute
soup whose only real power we've seen so
far is her eyes can glow pink remember
that Sam has never had any friends so
when these guys show him a good time
toss him some beers and allow him to
slide down the hallway it's a whirlwind
of new experiences for him thus he joins
them as they make their way to the gulan
town hall on TV Andre and Kate watches
polarity condu an interview with Cameron
Coleman he's scheduled to interview
Victoria at today's Town Hall but
spontaneously starts to convulse causing
his powers of magnetism to cause chaos
on Set Andre hasn't talked to his father
since he learned he was complicit in
what's going on in the woods it seems
like there's no one left in Andre's life
that he can trust but seeing his father
in trouble compels him to run across
campus and ride with him as a global
Wellness ambulance picks him up Global
Wellness is the Spot Run Health
Organization where do you turn to fill
that void adrenochrome laced
cocaine heroin enimas it's also pretty
funny to see a VA pharmaceutical ad on
the television as Andre runs off Emma
arrives back with some delicious VA
Burger pass a TV with the latest gulkan
rankings with Andre Marie and a random
third student in the same positions she
is shocked to find that Sam is missing
with Andre by his father's side polarity
experiences another seizure causing the
insides of the the ambulance to crush
them like that Submarine by the Titanic
Andre has to use all his powers just to
keep the truck from imploding but the
question I have is what is causing these
seizures is it just a normal health
issue did someone do this to him or
could the seizures be a side effect of
compound V seizures can be the result of
a multitude of factors from genetics
brain injury stroke or infection if it
is some sort of blood clot could Marie
end up saving his life by using her
powers and can we just take a moment to
realize the real MVP here this paramedic
got the stretcher slammed on her and
scissors and fire extinguisher slammed
on her face girl better be getting a
raise Emma knocks on our ra Maverick's
door to see if he's seen Sam of course
he's there with Sloan the alpaca who we
still don't know is a real animal or
soup who can shape shift I really liked
Maverick last episode where he was
comforting to Jordan but here he
basically tells Emma to screw off
because he's getting ready for sexy time
go [__] block someone else Rufus lies
once again to Sam stating that they'll
be meeting Emma later in a pinch Cameron
Coleman has filled in for polarity to
ask Victoria the hard-hitting questions
Victoria speaking at gulkan is an
attempt to bring some understanding to a
group of people who see her as a threat
she comes at a time when views on
superheroes have plummit it we had
Stormfront come out as a sadistic Nazi
Soldier Boy a Russian spy and homelander
himself killed a Starlight supporter in
broad daylight one attendee even asks if
homelander will be held accountable for
his actions with Victoria stating she's
confident the legal system will try him
justly by a jury of his peers but can he
be tried justly when his peers are all
human in episode one we saw a brief
television report in which we see
homelander lawyer state that he stood
his ground in episode two we'll learn
this trial is underway so it'll be
interesting to see whether homelanders
trial will be a plot point for the boy
season 4 or if it'll be resolved by the
time it starts Newman notes that because
of her work at the fbsa both human and
superhuman incidences have dropped by
30% and that if she and singer are
elected they'll establish a new role in
government so that superheroes will have
a voice the crowd does not believe her
with Rufus joining in a chant of you
will not control us they get
increasingly agitated as we see an
electricity soup a green one who looks
to emit radiation scream girl and one of
rufus's buddies use his laser eyes to
rip off an American flag security is
quick to Usher Victoria away meanwhile
Jordan has created a distraction by
dislocating Justine's jaw the girl who
posted about Emma's eating disorder on
her YouTube channel we have Harper over
here the tail girl we saw posing for
Justine in episode 2 documenting the
whole thing stating that this will
surely result in Jordan losing her fifth
place ranking but because the camera is
knocked out of our hands we can't be
sure if this footage survived the
distraction is a success allowing Marie
to catch Victoria as she's ushered off
stage and to Marie's surprise Victoria
knows who she is after all Marie made
national news a few days ago fighting
off Golden Boy and becoming the guardian
of gulan in fact Victoria mentions her
daughter Zoey who we saw Victoria give
compound V2 is a big fan of hers now we
don't know how Zoe's Powers manifested
if any manifested at all all we really
saw is her spine spasm as the compound
was injected I'm curious whether or not
Zoe has the same Powers as a Victoria
and Marie it may Explain why both she
and her are quote big fans of Marie the
show might even be teeing up a potential
face off between Zoe and Ryan homelander
son we know that homelander and Victoria
don't necessarily see eye to ey so could
this animosity pass on to their children
Victoria asks oh come on tell me
something about myself she wants to know
if Marie can sense the compound V in her
blood this whole season has seen Marie
discovering a more about her powers and
this appears to be the first time she's
used it to discover compounds in
someone's blood Dr card DOA said that
Marie could be one of the most powerful
soups alive so seeing what other things
she can do with it will be interesting
to see over the next few seasons for
example will she be able to pop heads
just like Victoria could she destroy
entire cities by simply exploding
everyone's heart to what extent do her
powers go after showing Marie she has
similar perhaps identical Powers
Victoria reveals that it was her who got
Marie into gulan now even if you've
watched the boys we still don't
definitively know Victoria's endgame
it's safe to assume with her as a VP
she'll want to off singer and become
president but then what Victoria puts
herself at Great Risk by revealing
herself to Marie did she help Marie out
of the kindness of her own heart did she
see how the two of them were similar and
thought she'd pay it forward similar to
how Stan Edgar saved her or does
Victoria have other plans for Marie
after all she tells Marie to keep in
touch perhaps even more concerning is
that Victoria knows about Marie's sister
Annabeth that's information that goes
above and beyond just being a fan of
hers what else does Victoria know that
she's not disclosing in episode 2 Haley
Miller stated that they contacted
Annabeth but she wanted nothing to do
with Marie something Dean ched says was
probably a lie to get Marie flustered
before her big interview we still don't
know where Annabeth is or if she has
powers like Marie if her parents gave
Marie compound V then it's possible they
gave Annabeth Powers too Marie tells
Victoria about the secret lab under the
school called the woods and instead of
Victoria jumping to action Maria's
shocked when Victoria's like tell handle
it she's just been given this insane
information and she just kind of brushes
it off what Marie doesn't understand is
that she has two paths in front of her
path one she tells the world about the
woods only to get crushed by VA thrown
under the bus the whole thing covered up
and she's left with nothing just because
she's this guardian of gulan doesn't
give her a pass that moniker was given
to her by VA and it can just as easily
be taken away Victoria says that's just
marketing So currently we're testing the
Guardians of gulan real power Victoria
exclaims resides in path 2 Marie
continues her schooling becomes the
first black woman in the seven and
becomes friends with the vice president
maybe then she'll be able to find her
sister and Victoria is Right Murray is
still naive in the ways of the world so
I think mie will keep her mouth shut and
continue on at culan meanwhile Emma
finds Sam who we start to see swaying
towards the ideology of Rufus and his
friends stating that he liked being with
quote people like us later in the
episode Sam will call what happens to
Dean Shetty Justice and if you put
yourself in his shoes it makes sense the
man was imprisoned for most of his life
and experimented on by humans and for
the first time he's now having fun and
feeling like he belongs with new friends
so of course he's going to hold this
animosity toward the people who did this
to him Kate meanwhile waits for shett at
her home and the first thing Shetty
notices is that she she is not wearing
her gloves so while she's chewed out for
manipulating Kate Shetty appeals to her
emotions both of them found Acceptance
in love with each other after tragedy
something that bonds them and with one
final push what Kate calls using her
power the two can leave gulkan and start
a new we never find out directly what
this final push is but I think they're
implying it has something to do with
killing the remaining inmates in the
woods tell them what your last
assignment was for me
kill everybody in the woods what I don't
understand is how Shetty tells Kate that
they'll leave soon but just a few hours
ago told Grace that the virus still
needs about 10 more months of research
to make it fully effective this implies
that Chetty never had any intentions of
leaving with Kate in fact I'd go so far
as to believe Shetty would kill Kate
seeing as she's really the only person
who could expose her we get a brief shot
of Andre in the hospital with a
stabilized polarity apologizing to his
father for not being around he along
with the others receive a text to see
Kate who's with Shetty and upon entering
the door a jar no less they find Kate's
eyes bloodshot an indication that Kate
has overused her powers she has shedy
completely in her control and now she'll
do whatever we want Shetty tells them
that gulan was founded not to train
soups but to study them She lays out her
plan to spread a virus that will kill
all soups this is when Marie puts two
and two together that Shetty Wants
Revenge on soup for killing her husband
and daughter in shetty's mind the very
nature of a soup is one of Destruction
you all leave a path of Destruction
behind you you can't help
it it's your species Kate says it's time
for them to strike first ordering Shetty
to kill herself while simultaneously
using her power to prevent Marie from
helping her this was definitely one way
to earn back their trust but surely not
the way they wanted her to do it how
exactly they plan on getting away with
the murder of the dean will be
interesting to see but knowing how
bigger cover-ups have been successful in
the boy Universe something tells me the
kids will be back at gulan for season 2
I mean technically the dean's death
would be considered a suicide that is if
no one finds out Kate pushed her to do
it the death of Shetty also raises the
question of who will become the new Dean
I'm assuming that season 2 of genv will
continue on at gulin which means someone
will have to fill this role the only
real adult with a connection to gulan is
polarity he's already a trustee and has
a soupon attending but of course he'd
have to get better from whatever health
condition he's suffering from if it
isn't polarity it could be someone we
know from the boy universe or an
entirely new character altogether the
final scene is one that will surely have
your head explode Dr cardosa has met
with Victoria to hand over the virus now
if you're cardosa this is logically the
best person to hand the virus over to
she is seen as antia and anti-p the two
people that would come after him should
the existence of a virus be made made
public the virus in its current form
isn't very contagious only able to
survive a few days at ambient
temperature he asked Victoria to hand
the canister over to the National
Institute of Health to be stored and in
return for him whistleblowing he wants
his family to be put in witness
protection but Victoria has other plans
after confirming that no one else knows
how to replicate the virus she explodes
cardo's head taking the container of the
virus with her now I have three
different theories of what Victoria will
plan to do with this I I think the least
likely of the three is that she'll
destroy it having a virus that could
kill a soup is just too powerful of a
trump card not to hold on to remember
that she willfully gave her child
compound V in a desperate attempt to
protect them from people who would do
them harm like homelander and having
this virus in a less transmissible form
actually works in her interest this way
she can Target specific soups with the
virus if she so chooses without it
turning into a global soup pandemic the
more believable theory is that she holds
on to it as I said it's it's This
brilliant trump card that she could use
to keep her soup enemies at Bay now the
third Theory and I think this is less
likely is that she continues to develop
it on her own the evidence against this
is that she herself is a soup and if she
created an Airborne version it would put
not only her life in jeopardy but that
of her daughters now if you want to
guess what happens in the season finale
join me in our trailer sleuthing section
where we take a look at the season's
trailers to sleuth out what's in store
there's only about three or four shots
we haven't seen yet so we'll go over
those the CEO aot Ashley Barrett looks
to be making a shocking Discovery here
at gulan I wonder if she'll make her way
to campus after finding out the dean
slit her own throat she could also be
doing cleanup after that disaster of a
town hall but from the crossover trailer
it looks like she could be here to find
a new member of the seven we need to
send someone straight to the seven and
look at that is that a resume for Andre
Anderson she's also here with director
Adam bour the two out a fling in season
3 of the boys something happens that
pierces their ears we know from this
shot that students attempt to flee the
dorms as some sort of lockdown takes
place could an alarm be going off and is
this lockdown result of dean shed's
death or perhaps inmates from the woods
escaping some other theories for this
mysterious sound include this device
seen in episode 2 but that's only
supposed to work on soups it could also
be Kate getting into the minds of
everyone on campus Marie seen here in
Dean shed's office experiences this
sound too here we have what appears to
be an inmate from the woods set free is
it possible Kate set them free remember
she was tasked with killing all them so
an act of defiance would be to set them
free now she wouldn't know about this
virus and it's possible these inmates
could be spreading it into the real
world which would require them to be
recaptured and quarantined something I'm
sure they wouldn't be too happy about
and our final shot is of Rufus who's
jamming out in front of his phone with
only one more episode left the first
season of gen V has really shaped up to
be an absolutely fantastic addition to
the boys universe but now I turn it over
to you what do you think will happen in
the finale leave your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching make sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram @
thinkstory YT until next time remember
holy
[__] a lot is
happening